so big following on Facebook we all know
million unique to our actual website
layer blog and what Madison and we want
to watch feasibly to to do the big
stress rating with Instagram now I'm
losing a little bit away from the
planning and giving Maddie well it's
funny because I just about to blurt out
this is your opportunity to do more
brandy there's a big difference between
the way HubSpot marketed the product and
a lot of other people and the reason it
was successful is they did vote how did
they do both back they spent money on
things that weren't directly correlated
to [ __ ] driving people into a
commercial run on selling yeah okay
everybody please please I don't know I
would tell you that if you can afford to
you would only invest in branding you
would only listen if you can afford to
got it
yeah because what branding does is the
following here's a brilliant branding is
getting married okay got it
yeah and selling is hooking up okay like
looks like like like like why did I buy
these not because they cook heed me
right I'm fascinated by that
it's why I'm winning right I'm branding
while everybody else is selling so how
would you go about it even the only
little things I sell he only previously
and shirts right like it's branding its
branding I want I don't give a [ __ ]
about the money
got it until people confused I'll go
people at Gary's say everything is free
I like sorry for the 13 dollar book
every three years you know like I'm like
a matte I don't need you to buy it
like I don't stop my sentences and then
put up a paywall
I get complete thoughts you don't need
to buy anything got it yeah even to my
point if people were smart enough to
understand what I'm actually doing I'm
doing branding where I make my economics
it's still just reinforcing ranting
speaking is branding its awareness
right like if I was like if I was like
I'm just laughing because you know how
easy it is for me to build a business
that's like hey everybody pay me $1,000
is when I'll give you a nice comfort I
mean it'll kill ah
go kill it'll kill I would make fifty
million dollars a year
yeah fifty but when you're trying to be
a billion dollar player you don't care
you know you think you've got more and
so I think I think people brand and sell
predicated against this talent for at
least their belief of their talent
the quickest way I know somebody doesn't
think they're big time is by their
short-term behavior now money is
important to make I'm left that I don't
need to monetize my audience in what I
actually do for a living and I actually
think what you're doing is smart like
you need to build content and those
things for your business but I don't
where I think you guys need to tweak is
you can't be 100% be ourselves you can
just start with 20% of all your stuff is
just for the branding of it all like tip
why don't you have a dinner with your 12
best customers and then film the
conversation and then put that out I'll
take this good but there you go
you've got it you're you're you're being
very intuitive like based on a couple of
things that are going on here you need
to get to the mark I mean how many
people the company is it smallest how
long you been a very do you have you
have the year of the CEO or the
marketing head that would make sense to
me it sounds like they're smart people
if you've got their attention you've got
my attention you need to push me like
ahead I want to step outside my bounds
of what I do but I believe in this and
Gary Vee said it was cool you know like
you've got to figure it out because
you're right
you're up your your your your body
language is going to the right place the
water is getting to the right place if
you think yeah do you think if you
get something you got with angel nothing
we've done benefits only no because it's
held oh I'm wondering do you think like
nothing but timing lines do you think
you'd be able to do a lot of it getting
back into doing now at this scale yes
the thing that I did the cut bill one
library
I'm just patience look what's everybody
in a rush for like I promise you if I
you ask everybody hey if you want to
make ten million dollars in three years
or do you want to make fifty million
dollars and 11 some people take the
pennant ring that's fine but I don't
know I like the 1511 I think people get
confused and unfortunately to document
this at the time so so there's something
interesting I was about to say I think
people get confused because I wasn't
documenting my life of thoughts when I
was actually being patient in my twenty
and now they see it well I don't think
people realize is I'm nothing compared
to what I'm going to be so when I'm
gonna be the guy like these not nice
cult status amongst the smart homies
then this is gonna be interesting
doesn't be real interesting when you
know when I fell a company for 1.7
billion there's gonna be really
interesting when I buy a brand and flip
it this would be really interesting when
I make my I know that I have another
Facebook and uber in me like when I make
that but I'm going to put five million
into it at a 10 million dollar valuation
on half of it and then this is going to
be interesting in 25 years when people
can ask me one question like would you
be giving back and I'm like yeah go
watch Barry be 158 you know what I mean
got it yeah my version of that was I was
22 year old kid and I worked every
minute that was my giving back I
couldn't fly people from Turin come kids
on my time I couldn't do these kind of
giveaway tons of slick but what I stayed
with my time when you don't have money
you give your time that was my patience
that was my giving back that was me
being in the store helping a manager get
better
7:00 p.m. to 10:00 p.m. on a Saturday
and training him on how I want to do it
instead of going home at 6:00 and going
to the city and having a D got it sex
well I meant I meant when we get there
to the airport one of the things I got
second in the tech world on my career
but I have a lot of friends I always ask
whether or not I wish that round thing
didn't I hope you like giving me any
desire to be your own thing today you
have such a confidence kind of vibe but
thanks sir but it's funny because my
answer was always no like I think I'm
very and until you said it in your
content I think it really stuck with me
like I'm not very good number two yeah I
get him in I think I think they love you
like back so I'm going to say something
that pisses me off that the rock is
catching this because I've said it here
and there but I don't think I've I don't
think I'm gonna be a big scaping this
one I secretly wish I was a member too
yes it's the best job you get you get a
lot of the economics a lot you get a lot
a lot a lot of the perks and a lot less
of the [ __ ] number two when you're
number one your professional gander when
you're number one you're in the
shittiest spot ever
you got it devastates me that my
hardwiring forced me into the Merida I
am obsessed with number two its luggage
it's the kid it's just great we still
can impact if you do so much and there's
just still something about not being the
last line of defense
you still get to look at somebody else
and go yeah and I mean for me the way I
am
theoretically I wish it was a number
care but for me like even it's so funny
even though I just made that huge rant
like I could never look at somebody and
say what are we gonna do you know it's
funny but it's a good gig it's a gig and
I think and I think even more
interestingly I think number three
influence I mean if you are
if you can be impactful there's people
my company that are number 57 but have a
lot of influence and that's a really
great gig you know but that's every
relatively that's right yeah that's
right that's right
maybe 52 at Facebook like growing
learning oh my god more money from a
financial standpoint number 52 at
Facebook it's going to make more than
99.9% of number one that's why I always
remind people that interact with me is
where I think the rock is very smart and
watching his whole narrative like you
gotta be smart when you catch a tiger by
the tail you really did you just told me
never to receive an erection
yeah right right right uh take with thee
with everything with you and I love that
I love the meritocracy of it all with
the people that jump off my ship I'm
such a son of a [ __ ] when it comes to
the competitive nature of business like
I love them and I feel sad and I want
nothing but great and I genuinely
genuinely genuinely wish they'd go on
and do bigger that if they stayed with
me I really I really do
however I'm excited too knowing that
that's probably not going to be the case
and I can't wait to see them that's why
I love business because you can be a
good guy and you can be an assassin at
the same time and if you know how to
balance that you can really pull it off
and I love that I love business like
that I love I love that it we can
pontificate back here I'm a number two
I'm the more I'm going to be all time in
it guess what it's going to play out
that's what I actually think what I do
is pretty interesting I'm always curious
about am I completely insane or is it
meant to be I do you know it's insane
that I painted such an aggressive
narrative that I've opened my mouth in
such a big way that I can achieve
unbelievable greatness and still be
looked upon as a failure by the masses
segregation yeah yeah like like high
percentage of people that believe in me
will be massively disappointed if I'm
not able to achieve four billion dollars
worth of net worth and being like oh
you're coming like like I can literally
be the first eight hundred I can be the
first person ever to make a billion and
be a loser is everyone your unit but you
know what's funny you know it's funny
you know twenty I actually as I said
here realize how much the journey is the
only thing for me like it's crazy to me
so it would be insane to do that and
it's crazy when you look the math of
what I'm doing and it makes me realize
how little it actually means to me like
just the legacy means more to me I
really mean it like I've really gotten
into a great place with this like I love
it I love the impact I'm having on
people what when did you realize this
point that you wanted to buy the dress
very early on
somewhere around fourth grade usually
yeah right around time I realize I
couldn't play for them other great these
other kids are faster bigger I better
just by you know tragedies yeah was a
competitive moon like okay your bow oh
okay you're better at it what about when
you play for me what about when I'm
signing your check dick that's what
happened a young age yeah that's better
yeah you know I'll be honest I uh I'm
real curious to see if one of my kids
has it because it is in hindsight it was
i mean people aren't blessed with it
ever let alone having it I mean so I
punted school I it took me a long time
to understand that about myself but
that's why I gave up on school knew
wasn't gonna matter and when you really
genuinely don't think it's going to
matter and you're in the fifth grade
sixth grade you know then you're able to
like kind of enjoy it
cuz I hated it but at least I don't have
to do anything yeah you know like I
didn't believe in anything that was
going on but at least I didn't waste any
time right I think in ninth grade
freshmen your high school which is a
pretty essential academic year I don't
think I opened the book I think I took
bookshelf
I think I put the brown paper bag and
covered them up you know protective
cover I think I drew on them I think I
put them in my book bag and I actually
believe that I never opened it
mint condition back so you flip this on
eBay pretty cool
why did you ever do call it if you knew
my parents wanted me to and I didn't it
wasn't a fight able to fight I tried to
have but my mom wasn't I wasn't beating
my mom my mom was my mom's undefeated
you know it's the true answer I would
have loved had not and actually that's
not true I'm so pumped I did it made me
grow up I grew I went to a really
hardcore college got very cultured met a
lot of stuff grew up I became a grown-up
you know you don't think you would have
done since no I think I would have been
different I think I think a lot of my
swag comes from the urbanization of my
four years of college which i think is
bodes well for me I think people can
taste it and so I think that worked
you never think these things for them
yeah you know what I mean like I mean
yeah I mean I mean the first day I
walked into college the internet didn't
exist to me so like let alone thinking
well you know what I mean this is what I
try to tell youngsters like you be rock
like yeah like you understand like
there's so much more to go yeah I feel
like we never realize what your
five-year plan is if I feel like we
thank you for taking my five-year plan
probably memory if I'm actually wearing
a maroon 5 years I mean though I
couldn't even imagine you know as much
as I predict like you don't have any
clue what the world is going to look
like in five years thank you Jesus way
too fast like waited
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]